ma sei una [ __ ] brutta ciao picaro o
in altro che figo ma quindi e ogni volta
stavano in un posto diverso come l'ala
sotto la vedi in teoria dovrebbe essere
la nostra tecnica ti buttare giù che
perdi vi è quindi cambiano le isole ogni
volta che spagnoli pensa fosse sempre la
stessa allora ti illustro in breve che
cosa dobbiamo fare innanzitutto saliamo
ok quella la nave bravo esatto e non
avrei fatto così non benissimo
ti spiego non andare non lo sapevo io
che mondo giocasta nuova con pierre tilo
sa sull'obiettivo e noi siamo pirati ok
vabbè style a sovana faceva apriamola
ancora scegliere che sia per quello no
quindi non suonare la campana non serve
a niente
ci spieghiamo le vele here we go
andiamo ragazzi e notte
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no ti ammazzo tutti i giorni ammazzo qua
sotto se vieni ti illustro uomo adam eve
nichi lui della barca però non guida la
barca aveva aveva la forma non sotto qui
vieni qua qui sotto questa è la nave ok
ma che figata bene che sono tutte le
isole che possiamo esplorare ma se io
per esempio si sun terra aiuto all'amico
ma faccio
come secondino dobbiamo andare lì ho
capito arrivo rallenta rallenta non
succeda ancora
si aggira questa pagina lo gira lo gira
gira quello di nuovo dietro travostino
stiamo cinesi a google aveva vai vai vai
vai faccio io perché questo è il gioco
risco a questo così si gioca scavalca ci
hanno colpiti dobbiamo liberare la roba
non sa dove dove le da quanto sei scemo
non voleva dell'acqua mi consoce laorca
lacca prendi un secchio redditi utile
numero il secchio non lo so io vado di
ciò però che devo guidare in barca a
questo buco non solo questo faccio io
faccio di tener premuto qt si apre
l'inventario al secchio 77 in tutto
quest'anno c'è una nave del resto cosa
sia forte come la vediamo madonna c'è
gente brutta ai cannoni faccio io e non
solo quelli che pensi che noi di pietro
io sparo jia jia rivista gira si sta
gira veloce nella vita abbiamo steccato
cometal seccato morto oggi stanno
saltando sono venuti recco a tutti sono
scemi che culo ai a chiamare la donna
che dolore
sono approdato sul viso anti io mia cosa
ho visto che brutta cosa hanno affondato
che comprende la nave mi sa che
[Musica]
sta andando a niente io vedo ancora la
nave nemica bastardi maledetti adesso è
dritto verso di mezzo uno che sulla
prova si è buttato in acqua addirittura
per iniziare e non ho colpi non vale la
macchia che bolt ha giocato e muovere
maledizione quanti colpi a mi ha ucciso
maledizione era impossibile cioè mi
hanno assaltato questo succede quando
morì nel covo dei dannati a era morto
quello che mi ha ucciso è morto luca
maledetto tanto ti spiega il volume si
giocano impiegato per niente levi a
saltare le isole rubare i suoi giovani
ho visto un po di streaming e portarli
all'autobus
ciao amico ciao ok bene almeno hai
capito quali gia io ti guarda la mappa
allora dico dove devi amare piuttosto a
destra destra che dirà completamente a
destra
vado di sopra guardare ok allora amico
pietro mi dica dove vado
va da ios parato sbagliato vada alla
pace un masso e lo dobbiamo evitare se
non facciamo la fine del titanic dritto
esattamente davanti a noi non sociale
dice nitra allora già vedo un relitto
laggiù dobbiamo cercare soprattutto sa
in cosa ai relitti delle navi verso
diritti di scusami e li trovi in giro
perché i relitti anno i tesori dentro è
ok ma lo facciamo relitto dove ci sono
dei gabbiani in genere ci dovrebbe
essere qualcosa allora occhio faccio io
l'atterraggio per l'attracco perché
credimi è più difficile quello che
sembra amico di piccola piario amico ma
il piano è tranquillo
no
faccio io riguarda quaquaraquà la skin
guarda skill palma via amico
parcheggiata proprio perfetto bravissimo
bene adesso vai a prendere il tachimetro
che se non così vanno la multa perdona
caverne ci sono dei simboli sulla
caverna quindi sicuramente là dentro c'è
qualcosa ma se c'è qualcosa qua aspetta
dobbiamo scavare una storia qua c'è una
tartaruga esatto era prova di stupido
dovremmo scavare un po ovunque tipo
piero angela perché se no scusami ma mi
vedo a sparare con l'amico amico ci sono
descritti i bravissimi
ok ok ha tirato io che lo sparo spara
spara è perfetto un mare di più e quando
sparì si risvegliano perda sceso certo
c'è una nave davanti a lei io dico che
se ci stanno sparando cosa posso rumore
non so il mio di marangon arabi vai vai
vai vai valutazione sulla ancora subito
subito immediatamente e arline joly a
salterei che la metà basta guarda lo
facciamo e prendiamo la nostra c'e
ripieghiamo tutto lino che il nostro mai
marinaio farvi vedere amico lo vedo che
ho deciso ormai gli store chiuso la
stessa grazia ma sulla stessa barca
il concetto signorno spara ma non sempre
ma io ho un metro che poi si sa che ci
ha colpito pure loro madonna rega pirati
dei caraibi può accompagnare solo noi ci
crediamo ci crediamo
vedrai vado sotto vedere se si deve
riparare ma lo ecco noi ci ha colpiti
spesso riparando stoffa tutto io sta
barca di paro navigo ma che hanno
riparato
tuttavia messo il secchio ok di vedermi
con meno male direi meno male c'è col
secchio dovuta all'acqua giu ci rendiamo
conto che poi due secchiate ed è
riuscito a tutta l'acqua è l'auto costa
1 posto mai aveva infilato dritto dritto
girare dritta tricase girando c'è
un'isola lima 6 orbo non la vedi c'è una
roccia gigante scherzavo pira tutto a
destra velocissimo pirati veloce via
tutto quello che devi fidare stanno
attaccando tra di loro quei due spero
sono un casino se fai cagate ancora una
volta ti giuro non ci stai dentro
ematici faccio stare capito perfino non
è ancora a fondo perduto è un reddito
mezzo ha fondato vai è un mezzo del
guado tra la facciamo e anni a fianco
proprio tira giù la ancora subito
progetto io ce la mandi buona fede ma
dalle mappe destra
vista
bene e va bene ma abbiamo ci siamo
ancorati quindi siamo appunto vari
saltarci sopra detto ok va giù the break
up della ford gen
vediamo come questa fortuna dell'aja ok
è una bolla di ossigeno così a meno di
riprendersi giocatore che sta solo palle
di cannone cesto ftase ingrosso più
controllo ad onna quanto è pesante un
rischio che a portarla potrà se c'è
altro tra l altro non pensa che chiami
larga addirittura il gioco non ci crede
è un accesso thrasher vai vai un tesoro
di halloween capiamoci sono fortissimo
tra l'altro molto più grosso di voi
contro contro volta mai mai mai stava
salendo la via via ma io sono ubriaco
come troppo c'è soft touch android
sottocoperta amico ma sono ubriaco
perché se non preacco e non lo so dove
informazioni da me ho bevuto mi sa che
ho bevuto del globe 21 giu amico sono
quasi metri ma dobbiamo andare o che
dobbiamo tornare nel south coast
aspettavi vado a vedere come siamo un
ottima queste sono torri di vedetta che
ci sparano un buon poste dritto ok dato
è uno scrigno stranissimo questo in
realtà credo che sia uno scrive
io politica mi vieni a vedere lo prendo
in mano o con la donna subito massimo
basta prendere in mano per essere
ubriachi quindi parla un sacco di soldi
se lo consegnamo visto che già solo
portarlo è difficile ben prima che credo
di sì spero di sì
cavolo che culo lo chiederei qua in
gabbia però non so come sia prestato
vabbè stiamo arrivando per bottino
ubriachi marci
non doveva attraccare c'è un ponte a
sinistra potrà fare anche un'altra casa
tipa da sinistra golden sun dark dawn e
albi tucson iniziare amico arrivo che ci
siano finalmente amico
la puntata amico te lo giuro dai
controllati in giro che l'ho buttata lì
siamo al mio bordo dare madonna
meno male che non è saltato chissà se
morivamo sono ubriaco marcio amico
aspetta che è un casino portare la roba
da ubriaco allora non so bene neanche
dove bisogna consegnarle le ceste quindi
figurati come consegna sarò badovini che
accade dal ponte che la vacca sta
eseguendo quando vedo il ponte tutto
ondulato di sul ponte ti sto vedendo
salve tenga e lui che devo insegnare ma
si assicuri che lui no se il chelsea si
prese il ces c'è stata in cross gold
rendo 36 d oro
mi chiamo ricky forte ai con questa
possiamo comprarci delle mappe perché ci
dice dove ci sono altre chest allora
canta ti aspettano diventato mi avevo
del buon rock alla locanda e giorgio e
kraken il polipo di giorgio ai ragazzi
spero che video vi sia piaciuto oggi
concludo quasi of thieves diventa sempre
più figo prossimo saremo in quattro a
giocarlo poi in 8 poi in 16 poi tutti
quanti gli iscritti ragazzi spero vi sia
piaciuto video ma se i tuoi più
giustamente mi piace anche questo genere
di notizia sapere se siete non ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]